une visite dans un centre de
distribution de médicaments pour bien
mesurer l'ampleur de la tâche le
gouvernement ontarien assure qu'il sera
prêt à distribuer les vaccins contre la
coved 19 dès le 31 décembre même si on
ne sait toujours pas quand ni combien de
doses la province recevra en plus du
réseau public de santé les pharmacies
shoppers drug mart et les entreprises
privées comme le distributeur de
médicaments mais qui sonne ou le géant
pur auditeurs participeront à la vaste
opération
les discussions sont également amorcé
avec les compagnies pharmaceutiques qui
fabrique les vaccins le général à la
retraite qui supervise déploiement dans
la plus grande province du pays
il est rassuré par ce qu'il voit on se
tient prêt à être partout au pays
toujours la même question pour les
politiciens qui aura accès en premier
aux vaccins lorsqu'ils arriveront au
canada pense que les canadiens
s'attendent à ce que ce soit équitable
en même temps c'est pas les politiciens
qui vont décider si ça va être basé sur
les recommandations des experts des
sentiers le général les lieux précise
que les personnes les plus vulnérables
ainsi que les travailleurs de première
ligne devrait être priorisé comme dans
les plans de vaccination en europe
son passé de militaire refait surface
en attendant l'arrivée des renforts
soient les vaccins le général hillier
retient à motiver ses troupes
les canadiens exténués et irrité par le
confinement et les autres mesures de
restriction au magasin uk
la croix rouge internationale réclame
une distribution équitable et s'inquiète
aussi d'un autre problème la méfiance
grandissante envers les vaccins contre
la coved 19 mai de manning confidences
distribution transport entreposage
méfiance d'une partie de la population
les défis à relever sont nombreux mais
le premier ministre trudeau espère que
la moitié des canadiens seront vaccinés
contre la coved 19 d'ici septembre
prochain
ici philippe leblanc radio canada
toronto